every year has its fair share of hives
and loads of the movies but some always
seem to stand taller than the others
with the benefit of twenty years of
hindsight 1999 looks like one of
cinema's greatest ever years and each of
these films as well worth rediscovering
as they reached their milestone
anniversaries these are some of the best
movies turning 20 in 2019 as a 20th
century drew to a close
society seemed to be spinning headlong
into something of an identity crisis
it's only fitting then that 1999 was
also the year that Fight Club abroad its
way into theaters and left the world
asking did you know the truth about
Tyler Durden unless you were a fan of
Chuck Paul the Knicks original book the
answer to that question was likely no
fight clubs twist as one for the history
books and has got to be one of the main
reasons why watching David Fincher's
film adaptation and fold was so much fun
part scathing indictment of corporate
and consumer culture party construction
of modern masculine mythos and part
exploration of white male privilege
Finch's film is a take-no-prisoners look
at a society on the brink of
self-destruction and in desperate need
of a little anarchy fronted by Edward
Norton Brad Pitt and the Marvis fully
manic Helena Bonham Carter
Aniki is just what Fincher and crude
deliver with the brutal and bleak bare
knuckle bolts that is Fight Club which
remains just as potent and full of
surprises twenty years after its release
though it takes a radically different
approach to the subject matter
Mike judge's office comedy off his face
seems largely cut from the same term
attic cloth as Fight Club after all
they're both concerned with the
soul-crushing materialism of society and
both follow an office drone so drained
by everyday life that they become
desperate to find a way out rather than
allow his hypnotist fractured psyche to
start an underground Fight Club slash
and a kiss revolution judges protagonist
takes a slightly less violent approach
to personal anarchy he enlists his
buddies in a scheme to shake down the
soulless corporation who works for if
you've seen off his face you'll know how
hilariously wrong that scheme goes but
the film isn't ready to concern with the
heist itself instead judge uses a
setting and plot of office space to spin
a not-so satirical laugh out loud fast
about so effortlessly corporations and
consumerism devour
individuality and while condemning that
culture office space is also the rare
kind of film that also understands I'm
many people are just fine toiling away
in the corporate digestive system as
long as they get to keep their sweet
Swingline stapler and that if you want
one of them well nobody's making you
stay oh oh and I almost forgot I'm also
gonna need you to go ahead and come in
and Sunday too okay spike Jones's wild
frenetic and endlessly creative film
Being John Malkovich may have netted him
an Oscar nomination for Best Director
but it was hardly his first gig in the
director's chair the adventurous
filmmaker had spent the bulk of the 90s
holding his skills and developing his
style while directing music videos for
the likes of The Beastie Boys Weezer
Sonic Youth Daft Punk and Bjork while
some directors naturally gravitate
toward gritty realism and dense personal
drama Jones ups to take those same
elements and bolster them with visually
arresting semi whimsical narratives rife
of absurdist flights of fancy and
breathtaking stylistic flourishes Jones
a style proved more than ideal for being
John Malkovich which was scripted by
Charlie Kaufman the poet laureate of the
outlandish and the eerily eccentric
Being John Malkovich which follows a
beautifully bizarre tale of a puppeteer
who discovers a portal into the head of
the titular thespian is dripping with
fantastical flourishes from both writer
and director
it features show-stopping performances
from John Cusack Cameron Diaz Catherine
Keener and of course Malkovich himself
it also takes more creative and
narrative risks than most films ever
dare making it not just one of the best
films of 1999 but also one of the
all-time greats it's almost impossible
to imagine now but prior to the release
of The Matrix almost nobody knew who
that were Chelsea keys were after all
they had just two films to their names
and one of them the perfectly dreadful
Stallone and Banderas led action flick
assassins had only earned them a mere
shared screenwriting credits even their
sleek inventive crime thriller bound
went over unnoticed upon release
needless to say expectations were
practically non-existent for the
Wachowski follow-up which was billed as
a tech-savvy effects driven action movie
featuring Keanu Reeves to say that with
Chelsea sees the world's attention in
March of 1999 would be a huge
understatement
not only was the matrix a heady
character-driven tale of man versus
technology when a mark it was also a
groundbreaking visual leap for
a shaped sci-fi cinema for an entire
generation and became a creative and
commercial success that there were Chow
skis could never quite repeat they can
at least take heart knowing that even 20
years after its release the matrix does
feel as fresh and profound as ever
after delivering back-to-back stunners
with his first two films director Paul
Thomas Anderson had many in the business
hailing him as a next Martin Scorsese
New Line Cinema stepped up to produce
his third and he delivered a sprawling
37 million dollar art film followed a
dozen or so loosely connected lives
through a single day and ever-changing
weather patterns in the San Fernando
Valley clocking in at a whopping three
hours and eight minutes magnolia marked
Anderson's most ambitious and personal
project to date it's a film that
seamlessly combined the directors
penchant for high melodrama with his
Flair of grandiose set pieces and
meticulously observed character driven
narratives all set against a billboard
sized converse and led by a near
supernatural sense of fate which is
barely even glimpsed in his earlier
works the result is a colorful mosaic of
a movie that proved to be one of 1999's
most challenging and rewarding releases
of all the fantastic movies released in
1999 few had quite the cultural impact
enjoyed by a night Shyamalan
spellbinding supernatural thriller The
Sixth Sense Shyamalan s masterpiece
arrived in theaters under a shroud of
mystery but thanks to a star turned from
Bruce Willis one of the greatest child
performances in history from Haley Joel
Osment and the mind-blowing twist ending
it became a legitimate cultural
phenomenon almost overnight it also
cleared well north of half a billion
dollars at the box office
earned a six Academy Award nominations
and made a household name of the man who
wrote and directed it over the years
Hollywood and Shyamalan himself has
repeatedly tried and mostly failed to
reproduce a bracing impact of the film's
twisty narrative because Shyamalan
vision is so skillfully executed and
vividly realized a sixth sense has only
grown in esteem as a result and the
film's hefty emotional impact still hits
home whether you know its secrets or not
in fact part of the fun of you watching
The Sixth Sense is searching for clues
that you missed the first three or four
or even five times through but what's
overshadowed by the film's twist is that
at its core the sixth sense is also a
tenderly observed drama about grief and
loss fronted by a troubled youth
learning to accept the burdens of a gift
he never asked for that Shyamalan fitted
such high drama into a genuinely
unsettling ghost story is what
makes a sixth sense the stuff of genre
legend just a week prior to the Six
Senses arrival in theaters another
stunning supernatural confection hit
theaters in the form of The Blair Witch
Project conceived and directed by
newcomers Daniel Myrick and Eduardo
Sanchez and starring entirely unknown
actors the groundbreaking no budget
feature follows three film students who
get lost in the woods while shooting a
documentary about a small-town urban
legend as they struggle to find their
way back to society it becomes clear
they're not alone in the woods and may
be being stalked by the Blair Witch
herself well that story might have made
an interesting enough horror film in its
own right it's how my rick and sanchez
executed and marketed their story that
really made the Blair Witch Project
stand apart from pretty much every
found-footage flick made before or since
the directors essentially dropped their
actors off in the woods orchestrated
spooky events on a daily basis and had
their performers shoot the action
themselves the resulting film it's
gritty and patently terrifying and looks
and feels just a little too real for
comfort the filmmakers even doubled down
on that realism by setting up a genius
marketing campaign that sold the film to
audiences as a real-life documentary the
stark realism both baffled and
enthralled critics and audiences which
helped make the Blair Witch Project one
of the most profitable movies ever
produced whether you like his movies or
not Stanley Kubrick is and always will
be regarded as one of the greatest
directors I'd ever left if not the
greatest whether it was any good or not
his final film was destined to be one
that cinephiles world would pour over
debates watch and re-watch until the end
of time so that ends a Kubrick who spent
his career testing the limits of cinema
with narrative Lee challenging and
morally ambiguous art films continued to
push buttons from beyond the grave with
his Moody and masterfully executed swan
song eyes white shirts based on a 1926
novella entitled dream story the film
follows a man who ends up at this crazy
kinky house where rich folks were creepy
masks and do even creepier kinkier
things and know that summation doesn't
quite illustrate the enigmatic power of
Kubrick's kinky semi surrealistic
nightmare it doesn't do justice to the
complex personal quandary to explore by
the husband and wife in question either
and nor does it divulge the sheer
amounts of blood sweat and tears
listen to the film's torturous
two-and-a-half year
production while we may never see
Kubrick's nc-17 final cut of eyes white
shirts the version which hit theaters in
1999 remains a haunting last work
absolutely worth pouring over debating
watching and re watching Tim Burton and
Johnny Depp may have hit a bit of a cold
streak of late but there was once a time
when that pairing was one of the most
exciting in Hollywood so when they
announced they were teaming up for an
adaptation of Washington Irving's short
story The Legend of Sleepy Hollow there
was more than a little excitement around
the project mostly because the story
died so well with Burton's ability to
make the bizarre and grotesque so
endearing and entertaining and that's
exactly what Burton did was Sleepy
Hollow which still remains a stunning
work of Gothic whimsy a crackerjack
piece of writing from seven scribe
Andrew Kevin Walker is largely to thank
Walker script transforms Irving's brief
and brutal Headless Horseman fable into
a complex murder mystery pitting the
skittish Ichabod Crane as Detective on
the hunt for what appears to be a serial
killer
of course crane finds something far more
sinister afoot in the town of Sleepy
Hollow and that never better tab helps
draw viewers further into the area known
with a performance at theatres between
awkward charm cagey confidence and nervy
unease thanks to a beautifully bleak
visual palette courtesy of Emmanuel
Lubezki as well as unforgettable
appearances from Christina Ricci and
Christopher Walken Burton and crew
transformed Irving's classic into a
gruesome gothic Fantasia that stands as
a pinnacle of the birds and Depp
cinematic dynasty check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]